tutti ragazzi e benvenuti avessero video
sono fatti j
oggi siamo su stealing dai movimenti
ragazzi sarebbe un gioco simile al
patron face quest
niente il più o meno ma siate in
tantissime ultimamente tra l'altro tanto
quanto è figo sto tizio perché c'è
sopracciglia staccate dal corpo ma mi
importa ragazzi con questi lindell
diamond bisogna rubare sto diamante però
non ho capito dovrei riuscire anche
bastin sneaking ma devo a provare un
diamante in poche parole entro piano
piano giusto e chi la legge bellissimo
col piccone certo non è successo davvero
c'era un creeper che mi esploso ha già
un senso incredibile sto gioco aereo
ok casa ma perché a intero sarebbe un
gioco dove le scelte sbagliate ti fanno
se fai la scelta sbagliata cioè nel
didietro evidentemente erano le scelte
giuste questo va bene vado vado di quad
ai caduti cali in tempo prima che chiuda
gli occhi un fatto ok io l'ho trovato
con miglia da subito e ragazzi stanno
andare culo non è possibile che ci abbia
azzeccato ma poche volte va bene
la poké ball giustamente a far fatemi
vedere che mi incazzo succeda è
fantastico ragazzi ma io amo già sto
gioco
usiamo ragazzi fornendo tutto a [ __ ]
ragazzino non so se è normale però ok
fantastico la poche modella scelta
sbagliata fatevi trovare un'altra super
machine dai e questo va bene
cazzo succede ai ragazzi il giallo a mo
sto gioco è fantastico ho fatto
schiudere un nuovo partito la cosa ma
perché era bene certo è fanta io non ho
parole per descrivere la bellezza di sto
gioco non mi ferma nessuna donna e
disastri a qualche parte nel midwest
centro del cast di contenimento si vabbè
ho capito hanno visto che ha fatto il
casinò al museo milan mi hanno beccato
ha vinto sto gioco e bellissima dokic
arebbe un tasto fantastico la facciamo
questo nucleare bene dove vado non vado
ciò nel culo perché mi sono ucciso da
solo niente ho lanciato una carica
nucleare sul museo per fermarmi ti va
bene mi sono abbassato la sola su un
deficiente può scegliere io di fare
qualcosa di meglio
facciamo metroid qui dentro e colpisci
slam no lo provate tutte ragazze alla
fine la piena al piede di porco che era
più semplice
sono andato su poche volte funghi che
cazzo è successo sono cascati dei
granchi per alla non era anche allora
che cazzo devo farle sono tornati
indietro [ __ ] che fa oh mio dio
sono entrato piccolissimo leone mimì mi
prende un anno lo sapete ci avrei
scommesso avrei scommesso mi avrebbe
ammazzato l'animale primis ha premuto il
tasto sbagliato prima forse dovevo
premere questo satellite pro versate
ok ok certo va bene ragazzi sono un
genio ora proviamo questo io non sono a
chi cosa sono sti pulsanti sta premendo
a caso una calcolatrice diviso zero
perché
ma perché ma qual è il senso lo provate
tutte quindi non ha senso ragazzi sta
succedendo
oh mio dio mio che cazzo fai uno dietro
un robot enorme perché dovevo rubare il
diamante invece me ne sto andando a
gambe se stai andando vivo solivo no non
ci fossero flat sono uscito ho vinto
cioè se ho vinto già allora voi adesso
mi dovete spiegare passo avevano in
testa i creatori di stop cosa gli è
passato per il cervello va bene così non
importa è stato meraviglioso ha battuto
la sua faccia alla fine ancora grazie
stato cortissimo pronta che ne se
riuscivo a entrare in testa invece che
che piano piano da allora bel bello
fantastic ram jump ono cliccato un caffè
è infatti doveva essere veloce a
cliccare la facciamo
kick
mi sa che non ho risolto tantissimo
proviamo a fare non so chi andrà tra
aran non fosse già scritto non lo so o
mio dio se l'ho fatta sono entrato
perfetto nessuno nessuno si è accorto di
niente ragazzi uno scooter dentro da
museo ma non sono cose normali ragazzi
la lancia in cina o mio dio jump come
soggetto che succedeva niente di buono
perfetto ma ragazzi ancora non ho capito
il senso di tutto questo
massa mazza perfetto questa o dio ma
perché il suo gioco ho già capito che il
sen non devo farmi domande anche bel
quadro tra l'altro proprio con lo scudo
perché l unica non sono a prefetto con
lo scudo andava ovvio che cazzo società
perfetti siamo il laccio la non so
neanche che cos'è a doha dualla più
perfetto adesso ho capito che faccia a
faccia nel film belli capelli bene scusa
ragazzi scusatemi se è passata una nota
cose regolari miseria due stelle ti
principia fantastico da scelto ragazzi
ora che facciamo roccia roccia però non
so neanche che aprendo mira dalla
madonna ciò a tre stelle adesso arriva
l'elicottero devo fare con questo ci fa
una bolla folla non so quanto possa
essere utile perché no infatti mi farà
dei proiettili una bolla a caso va bene
ogni volta ok adesso quattro stelle ma
adesso c'è il pronto e che cade panda
ragazzi sempre nella merda perché mai
sia un ponte distrutto ricco questo
spero di fare la scelta giu ma pensavo
fosse la scelta giusta perché era più
lontana la va a fan culo il diamante
geniale sommossa stato un genio lo sono
sono gravi
faccia ragazzi è stato meraviglioso
perché non c è stata la cosa più ma che
cazzo fa a si sta scatenando fantastica
se avete bisogno di rubare un diamante
da qualche parte sapete chi contattare
perché io non intendo complimenti per
questo gioco fantastico cioè stato etico
creola son perse il titolo è piaciuto ma
sotto sotto fumetto mi piace anche a
pagare facebook con i video sta la
tradizione sono se l'avessi di scrittori
ci vediamo al prossimo video delle
ragazze